How long do we have to wait to see Mark Wahlberg
sporting Sully's iconic mustache?
And what's up with that prison scene?
Here's what happens at the end of "Uncharted."
Based on the beloved video game franchise,
"Uncharted" serves as an origin story for
rugged adventurer Nathan Drake, played by
Tom Holland.
Nathan is a street-smart bartender in New
York when he's approached by Mark Wahlberg's
Victor "Sully" Sullivan about teaming up to
find the lost gold of Ferdinand Magellan.
Sully explains that he was originally partnered
with Nate's brother Sam, who appeared in "Uncharted
4" and "Uncharted: The Lost Legacy."
"I think you're here because of your brother."
"Wait, you know my brother Sam?"
While Nate hasn't heard from Sam in years,
he can't help but be intrigued by the prospect
of finding the treasure Sam told him about
when he was a child and possibly discovering
what happened to his long-lost sibling.
Competing with Sully and Nate to find the
gold is the ruthless Santiago Moncada and
a deadly mercenary named Braddock.
However, by the time the entire cast of characters
is on a plane bound for the Philippines at
the end of the second act, Braddock shows
her true colors, slitting Moncada's throat
so she can collect the treasure herself.
It's at this point that she and her henchmen
catch on to the presence of Nate, Sully, and
their ally Chloe, who have stowed away.
Their fight in the cargo bay leads to the
film's most eye-popping set piece in which
Nate is swept out of the plane with several
large crates.
When he finally manages to make it back, things
go from bad to worse, leading to the film's
final act.
Nate climbs the boxes of cargo and dives back
into the plane.
However, before he can settle down for even
a second, Chloe, who is also battling Braddock
and her goons in the cargo hold, drives into
him and out of the plane in Moncada's little
red sports car in an effort to escape.
Things don't look good for either of them
for a moment, but Chloe soon reveals that
she has a parachute.
Through a stroke of good luck, she manages
to save herself and Nate.
They make it safely to the ground — but
they're in the middle of the ocean sitting
on top of a box of cargo.
Fortunately, they spot a crowded beach, and
then find a room for the night.
Throughout the movie, Nate reads and re-reads
the postcards his brother Sam sent to him
through the years.
These are postcards Nate now knows Sam sent
while he was working with Sully to find Magellan's
gold.
Now that Sully has told him his brother is
dead, they're more precious to him than ever.
As Nate looks over the map and the two crosses
that serve as keys to the location of the
treasure, he turns his attention back to Sam's
postcards.
He then thinks of something that hadn't occurred
to him before: Sam could have left him a clue
to finding the gold in one of the postcards.
In the flashback scene that starts the movie
reminiscent of the flashback from Uncharted
4, Sam leaves Nate a secret message when he
escapes from the orphanage where they live.
Young Nate uncovers the message by shining
the flame from a lighter on the back of the
paper where the message was embedded.
Now, Nate uses the same technique on Sam's
postcards and discovers his brother did, indeed,
leave him a hidden message.
The invisible ink he finds on one of the postcards
tells him that the crosses can also serve
as a compass.
Just as Sam seemingly intended, Nate uses
the crosses to find the coordinates of the
treasure.
Now that he knows exactly where to go to get
the gold, he has to decide whether to share
the news with Chloe.
Throughout the movie, Nate has been quick
to trust, especially when it comes to Chloe,
and he's paid the price repeatedly.
Now, however, it seems that Nate finally realizes
that he can't trust Chloe to stay loyal to
him or keep his best interests at heart.
So before he goes to sleep, he leaves out
a set of fake coordinates for Chloe to find
in case she wakes up before him.
Just as Nate suspected she might, Chloe takes
the bait.
When Nate wakes up, Chloe is nowhere to be
found and the fake coordinates are gone.
While Chloe is off on a wild goose chase,
Nate takes a boat and speeds out to the location
of the actual coordinates, a cave in the middle
of the ocean.
However, when Nate gets there, he discovers
that the cave doesn't contain just one ship,
but two.
Nate boards one of Magellan's timeworn ships
and starts to explore.
As he does, Sully arrives and is delighted
to find that the ship contains barrels full
of gold.
Between that and the value of the historical
ships, Sully knows he's in for quite a payday.
After all,
"It's the biggest treasure that's never been
found."
Unfortunately, the celebration is short-lived
because Braddock and her henchmen appear in
the cave.
Nate and Sully are vastly outnumbered, so
they hide in the ship as Braddock takes in
her discovery.
As they wait, presumably, for her to take
what she wants and go, Nate and Sully realize
Braddock has something else in mind entirely.
She has summoned two large helicopters to
fly the intact boats out of the cave so she
can bring every bit of the treasure back with
her.
After each helicopter is attached to one of
the ships with ropes, they begin to lift the
ships out of the open ceiling of the cave
and start toward their destination.
Since the ships are now completely in Braddock's
control, Nate and Sully are going to be revealed
eventually, so the two know they're going
to have to fight.
Since Braddock and her henchman are on the
ships as they're being transported, it's not
long until a full-on brawl starts.
While Braddock and her henchmen don't hesitate
to attack Nate and Sully once they reveal
themselves, the duo is every bit as determined
as Braddock to get the treasure.
Even though the pair know the other ship is
lost to them, they do everything they can
to establish control of the ship they're on.
This results in a battle involving clubs,
guns, swords, knives, fists, and anything
else the combatants can use.
In the end, Braddock's henchmen are vanquished
and Sully manages to gain control of the helicopter
carrying the ship.
However, Braddock is still standing and Nate
turns to face her as the ropes holding the
ship to the helicopter start to give out.
Nate and Braddock know they don't want to
be on the ship when the ropes break, so they
start to climb the ship's masts and the ropes
attached to the helicopter.
Ultimately, whether or not either of them
makes it out of the situation comes down to
Sully in the helicopter.
Yet, Sully also has his hands on a bag full
of gold, which may be more important to him
than anything, including Nate's life.
Nate scrambles toward the helicopter and reaches
out his hand to Sully, but Sully pauses.
Just when it looks like he's going to let
Nate fall with the ship, Sully drops the gold
and grabs Nate's hand, pulling him to safety.
The bag of gold falls into the ocean, along
with Braddock.
Then, the ropes attaching the ship to the
helicopter finally break and the boat crashes
into the sea, right on top of Braddock.
For a glorious moment, the ship floats on
the water.
Then, as Nate and Sully watch from above,
the ship crumbles and slowly sinks into the
ocean.
Nate suggests they could still salvage the
treasure from beneath the sea, but Sully points
out a Filipino government boat is already
on the scene.
There's no way he and Nate could get to the
treasure before they do.
Just when it looks like they're going to go
home empty-handed, Nate reveals he's stashed
several pieces of gold in his pockets as a
thrilled Sully flies them away.
While Nate and Sully's first cinematic adventure
together has ended, Nate still doesn't know
all the details about what happened to his
brother.
At one point in the movie, Braddock indicates
that she killed him, and Chloe and Sully make
it clear that they both believe Sam is dead.
However, the final few moments of the film
reveal that none of the characters really
know the truth about Sam's fate.
The scene cuts to a dark prison.
In a small cell shrouded in shadows, a prisoner
with long, unkempt blonde hair is writing
a postcard that looks like those Nate had
previously received from his brother.
Although the camera never gives us a good
look at his face, this must be Sam.
Beyond that, the postcard he's writing seems
to indicate he's been trying to contact Nate
for a while, but he's not sure his messages
have actually been getting through.
Following that brief glimpse, the credits
roll.
Finally, in a mid-credits scene, the movie
sets up a potential "Uncharted" sequel.
Nate is seen meeting with a man with an eyepatch
in what looks like a tropical cafe.
They are there to make an exchange: the ring
Nate wears on a strap around his neck in exchange
for a Nazi map that presumably leads to a
new treasure.
Just as it seems like the negotiations are
about to go south and Nate is preparing to
fight the man's allies, who have him surrounded,
Sully shows up with a gun and the pair regain
control of the situation.
Nate grabs the map and throws Sully, who's
now sporting a mustache and a cigar.
Sully sniffs the cigar appreciatively as Nate
joins him at the door only to show the man
with the eyepatch that he's also taken back
his ring.
As the pair walk out together, Nate expresses
his annoyance with Sully, who was supposed
to arrive the day before.
However, Sully explains he was late because
he had a hard time getting his cat, Mr. Whiskers,
who he's now carrying in a backpack, through
customs.
As they talk, the pair turn and stop dead
in their tracks.
Whatever they see in front of them seems to
startle them both, but before we can see what
it is, the sequence cuts, and the rest of
the credits unspool.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.